so our attorneys spiral inward turning
spiral okay but let's look at another
universal aspect of the artist oh he's
coming in and I have that same falling
geometry so there's the diagonal in this
frame you see that see that right and
then there's that hip mark and that
you'd universally throw everyone
utilizing that diagonal because it is
the most efficient following geometry
for a topsy-turvy effect ie having this
head shoulder neck region be the target
on the planet got it okay okay so don't
have your your in returning spiral going
back towards where the our Chinese files
go they don't do the same thing so our
Trey spiral is just freeing his energy
that way much like the two weapons
videos right that we did this week this
hand goes to zero pressure it goes
around and reconciles all that energy
that's what the in hand
the young hat doesn't go back that way
that would make them the same and that
would not make it Universal so in front
of me please
so this tag goes to the back corner as
it's yielding to get pushing energy and
this man looks for the X pattern across
so long boat
so this one is going that way
so without moving in come on marshal up
without movie dude I'm just working that
next pattern never making both hands do
that line or both hands do this love
their doing different things
hey hey the next aspect that makes it
Universal is why it's also called Co Q
so this hand is going to go in and then
the young hand of this young while
oriented on the X pattern is not
projecting on the X pattern it's not let
me say it's not pushing on the X pattern
it's aiming on that vector but this hand
is bringing them along to that young
energy of my face on the ground that
crowd path okay so you're not going like
this you bring him on pulling onto this
you got it mmm so you get that
projection point so he comes he's gonna
push him and he'll hit boom
now if okay disengages then you won't
hit it or if you can't absorbs in the
elbow you won't hit it but the assigned
intention is you going that way you hit
it right let me grab you
this is the signed attention this is not
the sign in case you see that so he
should be able to push boom and hit it
boom bush oh that's all we're gonna do
it so I'm starting up Oh Bush oh yeah
I'm making it very compact to train
myself not to push boom boom
I have to operate internally boom
you can stand up with and he's pushing
oh okay let's try okay so we're not
we're not we're we're micro drilling do
you understand alright so I'm not doing
the technique I'm just taking the part
of the technique boom this part okay so
she's just giving me her weight right
and you can see that the organization
right there I have I'm not like this so
I'm here right
lean on me alright I'm working with that
hey so I'm going here boom and I just
want a little percussion out of my boot
kid but she hits that wall boom boom
there again she pushes same organization
so I'm not using my feet the brakes okay
[Music]
you guys started getting closer and
closer to the movement yeah I'm doing
that inward boom boom hey okay so this
part gets him to drop him on that spot
and that percussive projection is okay
so don't make your arms go like this
it's not a it's not a our manipulation I
mean you're twisting him so he's off
balance that that's not the heart so
then this can't be universally
representative of the heart
okay so he goes Boop he hits that spot I
bring in them onto it
and I can add the projection from my own
[Music]
take a seat gates not exactly rolling
right here because there is a projection
so if I just twist my arms he kind of
rolls
he gets slinky there see but I'm
projecting through his cut up
[Music]
not slinky you see the difference all
right
okay so we'll let you get let go so you
can test whether you have that
projection or not
you
so again remember you have all of these
different aspects that are playing with
you Nanyang so that you can have a
technique that is representative or or
consistent with the pattern of the
universe good so right now you have a in
architectural pattern but you don't have
been on the inside it's very tense and
so you don't really have begin our
contention that this hand is very soft
this is very soft very small just hands
like a fire hose oh okay alright moving
on another universal aspect is the
narrative of the technique it's going to
go he's going to come in so he's young
right I'm going to reconcile the young
right through this yin and yang
manipulation matching harmonization and
then the narratives go to reverse I'm
now going to become young he's going to
become yet do you understand that
and so what another aspect of the art is
you will feel that every time young is
the violent aggressive action he's
coming in I reconcile it through yin yin
young parry
then the overall narrative changes he
becomes Yin I become young and I have to
fill that gap okay so as as he comes in
and he hits boom there's a spot where I
can and I walk freely because he's now
he in
I'm not using my movement in young
fashion against his young so I'm not
moving and you know I push them that's
not the heart you will feel this
technique go off its off me now and
that's when I'm walking into that
opening you understand tight so don't
use this to go home when you feel like
that that's not the art that's young on
y'all so the whole narrative changes
boom and it's free movement okay here at
the bottom I'm not trying to pin him
this is not a pin this is just another
static representation or rep of my coach
cue projection okay so he's pushy and
he's not gonna move me it doesn't matter
that I'm off to the side so stay there
I'll be way off to the side you can even
push this in he pushes he can't move it
you see that so don't over emphasize
this penny
and as you do both sides you're working
on that aspect of your body so do you
see how I'm centered here on my spine
but my hands over here you see that
don't go like this just stay here he
pushes he can't change the structure
push hard
just hit styrene fruitcake
[Music]
so dynamic projections that execution
here so go ahead and push you can see
I'm relaxed but inside I have structure
okay
all right right